Suba Asami has never had it easy she
lives in a 10 or 15 square metre
corrugated iron heart with her husband
and son near Kathmandu every now and
then she works as a day laborer at
construction sites or in the fields
earning the equivalent of three or four
euros but she sees no need to complain
and says she's happy the only thing that
really bothers her is discrimination as
a Dalit woman I faced many problems
living here I'm a day laborer when I
work for someone in an upper caste house
they usually don't give me food I have
to go to a cafe at the cafe they ask me
to eat my meal outside and rinse off my
dishes myself Dalits are traditionally
considered impure in the caste system
they're the lowest of the low that often
means being denied access to education
and jobs and above all a lack of respect
[Music]
the centuries-old caste system is rooted
in Hinduism many believe that their own
fate is determined by destiny and with
good karma their soul might be reborn
into a higher caste
[Music]
many Nepalese are deeply religious
especially in rural areas high in the
Himalayan mountains
[Music]
the village of Ravi Opie is a two-hour
drive from Katmandu its slopes are steep
the soil is dry and now the monsoon
season is about to begin
bommana toll on J belongs to the media
caste the mountain Dalits she faces even
more hurdles due to a lack of well-paid
jobs her husband has left the country
now he works in Malaysia's oil industry
but Bheem Allah doesn't know exactly
what he does
last summer he left for at least three
years he's never seen their young
daughter it would be so much better if
my husband could stay here in Nepal if
he'd found a job in farming or some
other kind of job he would be a helping
hand he could take the children to
school or help when someone is sick but
we have no choice thanks to her
husband's earnings Bhima a toll on Jay
has some livestock her house is larger
than some of the others here she used to
mainly tend to the household and work
from time to time as a day laborer
but then her life took an unexpected
turn the international climate
protection and Development Organisation
iCIMOD began providing agricultural
training to women in the region giving
priority to those whose husbands have
left to find work a project coordinator
from a local NGO pays regular visits
today he's showing the women the correct
way to plant tomatoes we practically
teach how to grow the plants or how they
can change the you know chemical
pesticides to the by pesticides so it's
not about teaching them it's about demo
organising demonstration plots practical
training authorizing field schools so
this is how we are training Lisa once I
wasn't all that interested in
agriculture and I only use traditional
farming methods
which don't provide much income after
the first people left to find work the
ones left behind just sat idle but now
we understand agriculture and we can put
our time to good use for many local
Dalits the program has been a boon the
district administration believes that
giving opportunities to the lowest caste
is long overdue the caste system in the
PHA follows a centuries-old philosophy
it divides society into forecasts with
Dalits at the bottom dollars have long
been part of our labor force supporting
development and improving society in our
societies undergoing very rapid change
it's becoming more inclusive this old
caste based way of thinking will be
eradicated very soon Dalits aren't so
optimistic they fear the long standing
discrimination they face won't change
anytime soon yet many Nepalese
especially the younger generation dream
of a country without a caste system the
village of Culture BC where EC mode has
launched its training program shows what
this future might look like the local
women many of them Dalits have joined
forces their farming operation is
thriving they'd invented a new kind of
organic fertilizer made of plants cow
dung microorganisms and water which they
spray on their fields these cucumbers
and pumpkins are grown organically the
women tell us every few days trade has
come by to pick up the vegetables and
then sell them at markets the project
originally aimed to prepare local women
for the impact of climate change
including droughts and erosion but the
women soon took charge themselves
ignoring caste distinctions in the
process NAND Kishore Agarwal helped get
the project off the ground we try to
work with the people to find out what is
the simple thing which they can do
themselves to to improve their
conditions to improve their say
livelihood or to to manage the change at
that time we did not even imagine that
it will go to
extend that it will really spread and
people will themselves to start doing
lot of things
soba Asami from the suburb of Kathmandu
has also taken matters into her own
hands she's building a larger house
progress is slow because she always has
to save up the money for the next step
but she's patient and determined and
she's no longer willing to accept
discrimination for being a Dalit
I'll get icky when you come to a bar as
any people don't understand we're all
the same they think I'm weak but I'm not
I'm strong enough to fight being treated
like that if some in the community don't
want to see it that way that's their
problem
I don't want to be treated like I'm
inferior to others I'll fight that
however long it takes for soba Asami and
others it's a fight for dignity and
respect and a future in which Nepal is
finally free of its caste system
[Music]
you
you